welcome everybody
i would like to introduce my director
for this year
the reverend katie cross from allstate
nicholas church who's going to say a
short prayer for us
thank you for inviting me i'll be saying
a short prayer but i'll leave a few
pauses just for you to gather your own
thoughts as we go through
almighty god
we left ourselves to you this afternoon
as we prepare to discuss the business of
this meeting
we pray that as leaders we would work
for the good of the wider community
seeking justice and hope for all
we pray that we would listen well to one
another and hear each other's points of
view
we pray for the places where we have
responsibility
for our towns and villages each with
their own opportunities and difficulties
we remember those who work there
those who benefit from the work we do
and those without work
we remember those who live there
and those who are without a home
we remember our health professionals and
emergency services those who care for
the old and the young
and those for who care in an unpaid
capacity
we remember our law keepers
educators local councillors and all who
keep society's wheels turning
may we bring our reflection and wisdom
to this meeting use our expertise and
our judgment and direct our
contributions
let us be listeners more than speakers
and may we always have in mind your be
will for the well-being and the future
of our community
in the name of jesus christ
um ladies and gentlemen before we
proceed any further
just to let you know
the microphones are live all the time
you do not need to press any buttons but
it does mean
that those little indiscretions might
get cast into the wider wider world so
with that thank you very much indeed
you'd like to sit down thank you
right first of all thank you very much
indeed for coming along today it's a
very warm day nice and pleasant in the
chamber
i would like to
extend a warm welcome to the students
from neonvale school and their teachers
and also the chair of the governors
uh for coming in today
for a
have a look around what's happening in
the in the in the chamber but also we
had our own debate
now
children who enjoyed the debates
on this channel
well i i really hope you enjoyed the
whole day so well so it's been great
seeing you all and i hope to see you
again at your school in the future so
thank you very much indeed for coming
along today
okay um let's start the meeting uh
mr buckland would you care to uh give us
apologies thank you chairman a number of
apologies today councillors curtis eden
both councillor ian presley and jenny
gradually councillor kendall councillor
pemberton council of wolf councillor
shenton and councillor wally hoggins i'm
adviser councillor o'donnell will be
late but he's planning to attend the
meeting thank you
thank you very much
members are there any disclosures of
interest on items on the agenda today
i take that as a no thank you very much
indeed
minutes of the meeting
uh can i confirm and sign the minutes of
the previous meeting are there any items
that
people wish to discuss or raise
no in that case then we need a proposal
may i have a proposal for that council
barca and the second council cattle
thank you very much
okay announcements
we've got the screens on
do we have these screens
yeah
that's this coming chairman thank you
[Music]
right
um it has been quite a busy period
uh
the last couple of months and also you
may
spot a familiar face in there
with job it's been there we have seen an
awful lot of each other lately
uh yeah
the uh the first event i went to was a
charles if you could go to the very
first slide please
and can you put it full screen i'd
appreciate that
that's it go forward thank you very much
indeed
uh the first one was the charles
clarkson tournament with the the mp uh
jeremy wright now interestingly
they there were a number of uh school
children at that event as well and it
was very interesting uh to
have talking about the environment uh
and ecology etc it really was an
interesting day obviously i was at the
mayor making next slide please
uh
then we had the ulster food festival
where i believe we had 25 000 people
tournament
the beacon lighting was very interesting
after a nice long climb to the top of
the welcome hills but i think the
fascinating thing from that was when we
actually
looked around and saw the other beacons
because it was a such a stunning view uh
from the top of there and then obviously
the civic service the next day oh yeah
so not not not up to the beacon i listen
to it this is not in order
uh the next item please
right the
two on the left was a job spare in the
fred winter center and that i found
quite fascinating
all of the exhibitors there
were looking for
staff for new employees every single one
of them was struggling for people and
it's a very strange situation we've got
quite a lot of employment but not enough
people to fill the pull the gaps
so that was quite an interesting point
and on the right hand side
um is chatty cafe
and this has been started up the local
cafe in ulster
born from rather tragic circumstances
where
uh two of us have committed suicide over
the pandemic period and this is all
about just having coming along becoming
a chat a cup of coffee
no pressure at all and it was really
nice to see so many people come up to
that to that meeting or
say more of a chat really was really
nice to see and hopefully it will carry
on into the future
next slide please
uh right that was the uh
we had the
mayor making in warwick which was i mean
talk about being outdone weren't we
there jill it was really quite splendid
backdrop to it
and then the bit on the right where you
can't focus on me is that compton
burnley
and met the
artist david bachelor who was putting on
a show there very very interesting of
course it's the armed forces day
in the interim next slide please
and finally um
we were at the opening of the
shakespeare marina
which was very nice today and again what
a fantastic facility for stratford
and that on the right-hand side is the
heart of england forest
having an open day for parish
councillors
thank you very much to that thank you
the next item i would just like to
make an announcement on
is
i suppose you could say
sad
sad for us
but very not sad news for caroline
uh most of you are aware i'm sure that
caroline is now leaving us for pastors
and you
uh she's been working at the council for
a number of years now shall i say how
many years yes sure yes 30 years
and started as a secretary now look at
that where she's come to now i can
honestly say that since i've been at
this council i've only known carol i'm
doing that job so well done and thank
you for that
we've also seen you
not just running but running around at
elections
and
helping out there on the on the counts
from a personal perspective i'd just
like to say thank you very much indeed
for your support
when i was chairing the democratic the
member development
committee
with your help support and enthusiasm
for that committee but also well i will
found it very important one to get the
training involved for members but
especially during covid
we still managed to maintain our
training we went online we did all sorts
of things and we still maintained a very
very good training program so again i
want to thank you for that
well we know she's not going far and we
do hope to see you
in at future elections
uh and then not too distant future so
there you are and a round of applause
for caroline please
[Applause]
thank you
the next item 95 on the agenda is a
rather sad one it's the
announcements from the leaders oh i say
apologize an absence from the leader
[Music]
thank you chair
uh three things to report
one i attended the garden party at
buckingham palace
this whoo
act together with council of fitter
so we were both there and it's a
very modest event with only 8 000 people
there
but it is quite a large garden
uh second thing is i had a meeting at
wellsborn
with martin yardley who's director of
the wellsborn campus
and neil rami who's chief executive of
the growth hub sorry of the west
midlands growth company talking about
developments on the campus and the third
thing is i went to the local government
association annual conference
back in god's own country in this case
harrogate
uh that lasted three full days very
interesting thank you
chief executive
thank you chairman just helping me um
thank you for bearing with us today with
the temporary sound system as you know
the sound system at the last meeting the
council was just not good enough and it
became more about the sound system
debate itself we are looking at a
long-term solution for the sound system
but thank you to dudley and his team for
for the system that we have in place
today secondly just want to join the
tributes to caroline caroline has been
an absolutely first-class democratic
services manager for us to just help out
on elections
caroline is integral in the running of
the election so thank you from for
myself as returning officer for
everything you've done for the council
over the last 30 and a bit years and
very best luck at that the town council
thank you
[Applause]
all right thank you now we can move on
to item five
uh membership of the council
um
and obviously following the death
of john horner um it is great with great
sadness we send out our our best wishes
today to john's family
over his sudden passing i i'm sure it
came as a shock to everybody it
certainly did to me at the time
uh john i met john my first year as a
district councillor
and then subsequently
uh as county councillors and we uh we
served on a couple of committees
together as well
uh
john always had his his thoughts and
views on life and i think we all accept
that
but he always brought a clear insight
into the issues in hand and was a valued
member of the committees he served upon
i especially welcomed his views when
sitting on the financial scrutiny
committee
and
he had such a breadth of experience
there and his great sadness that we uh
say farewell to him would anyone last
like to speak sus uh council jr
and then council party council
[Music]
i i worked with donald county when we
sat on the fire and rescue committee
when talked taking place in
worcestershire warwickshire
this meant many trips to worcester and
as we scared several car journeys i got
to know john little
our politics were dissimilar but were a
rich source of conversation
polite hard-hitting friendly john was a
man i admire and look forward to his
clear incisive views
it was such a shock to hear of his
unfamily fasting just as he was looking
forward to chairing the camp council
his calm voice and gentle humor will be
still missed in these overseas times
we may all differ passionately but we
can only make progress by hearing each
other and john was a man worth listening
to he will be missed
thank you very much
council parry
thank you jim
um
i was very shocked and very saddened
on the use of john horner uh i'd known
him as a family friend for nearly 30
years
um
he also apart from being a district
councillor helped hugely as a mentor
when uh account being a county
councillor
for those who don't know he was a
phenomenal rower whilst at cambridge
university
where he met so many wonderful people
and i think having been to cambridge
his
mind was outstanding and we all benefit
benefited from from his
intellect his forensic approach and his
sheer brain power
but as well he always had a wonderful
great sense of humor
obviously he was a very close family
man
um had many many friends
having attended his funeral with a
fantastic tribute
and celebration of his life and
achievements
he'll be greatly missed
by everyone who knew him thank you
thank you casa perry council kettle
thanks chad
um yes i will miss john
um
where
the report would be
many pages long
or other people would talk for hours
john would summarize succinctly
in about two sentences
what the main point of whatever the
argument was and whether the argument
was a good one or a bad one
um quite often
he was quite uh
awesome in his view but always very very
gently presented
um
my colleague anne has talked about his
intellectual capacity uh he didn't just
go to cambridge he went from cambridge
onto london university he then went on i
believe to princeton
um so by the time he arrived here
having spent time in the oil and gas
industry
um he was
a a remarkably
well-trained uh and um educated
individual
worryingly for those who've taken on
some of his chairmanships because trying
to follow that is going to be a serious
challenge um
but i he was here when i started on this
council
uh he was very kind very helpful
very supportive of young and new
counselors and the less young
newcastlers
and to give them the direction
uh i definitely needed
uh we will all miss him thank you
thank you council kevin
members would you
well sorry council trump i didn't see
you saying yes apologies
thank you mr chairman sorry it was a
hiding back here
um certainly john was a man worthless
the high intelligent articulate
spoke a lot of sense of analysis
he went from being a superb rower at
cambridge to a councillor who likes to
have a row
so certainly
certainly
i always looked up to him
attractive charming charismatic and well
loved by the electorate and i'll see
what i love boys family and friends too
a great loss to local government and
politics
and
it's a sad loss that the county council
will be having this chairmanship so my
best thoughts and wishes go to his
family and friends thank you
thank you councillor
members would you follow me please
standing warning silence
thank you
uh
so thank you
and there is no public participation
today um oh sorry i do apologize thank
you thank you um
i would like to move the following
notion
of my motion move the following to
council that this council notes with
regret
the death of the former councillor john
horner and extends its sympathy to his
family and friends in their loss
okay
okay no public participation
so moving on to the next item
[Applause]
and that is item 7
minute 717 local government association
model council code of conduct ancillary
documents
to
consider the recommendation
from the order and standards committee
as contained in minute 717
of its extraordinary meeting held on the
27th of april 2022.
i invite councillor fitter
uh introduce this item
just a second
sorry
just to explain to council and and thank
you for counseling pointing out to me on
friday what you're being asked to do
today is
agree that the complete suite of
documents to support the code which was
adopted in february council and we did
adopt some other documents at that point
but these are not going to be superseded
by the documents here today there's also
reference in the documents to working
with warwick district council
we need to remove those as a part of the
final edit and the recommendation that
council has been asked to approve this
afternoon would give phil the
flexibility to to amend those those
editorial changes if you like to remove
the references to warwick so edward
thank you sorry castlevania uh thank you
so there was an extraordinary meeting
held at the end of april
committee this was fed by council andy
trump
at the um that are on page that's for of
our agenda um
thank you
thank you
um i have a
um
a proposal do you have a sector for this
council dixon
um right members of michigan speak
councillor
uh
he said he and i spoke
and then very much support the
recommendation i've been at the meetings
where
and it's nice that we're going to get a
consistent um
code of conduct across across the county
the local government association um
so
hopefully when this is all done and we
get these corrections done we've now got
dealing with it um
i'm hoping the monitoring officer
i don't want to cut down a load truth
unnecessarily but i think it's very
important in these times that we all do
see the document that we're all working
with
is a bit of our bible and i believe
mr bob is going to work with
grafton
perhaps because of training sessions on
to make sure we all understand that i
think that's fighting for
the present situation so i think
was both experienced
and the other question i would point out
in in one of those various things that
result in this
is that the the model code of conduct
being promoted to parish councils and
those of us that have got
a lot um
because we've got a common monitoring
officer
it would be a great benefit that as many
as possible of those parish councils who
are all working the same code
will understand what we're doing
what i'm not clear is how we're setting
about doing that whether we've already
set that in training but the councils
have
but
i'm not sure who i'm asking the question
of but i think we need a methodology for
addressing that and driving that into
the parish council as much as we
possibly can thank you very much
chairman thank you council crumbs
thank you mr chairman yeah obviously as
councillor mentioned i was the chair of
that uh committee at the time when it
was adopted and
cancelled the rockets still and one of
my parts my thunder regarding promoting
it to towns and parish councils which i
think is of utmost importance
and i think it'll if that was the case
would help mr graf news as well
the other point i would like to mention
was that during the review of the
process we involved we were talking with
white district council at the time and
their independent people
as well as our independent people worked
on this with with councillors so he had
a real balanced view on this and uh what
we came up with um
the proposals i think are fair and
reasonable and it gave the monitoring
officer flexibility to to work with the
chair of auditing standards to monitor
or should make minor modifications so
again that's that's makes sense wrong
having to come back here all the time so
i wholeheartedly support the
recommendation
and
hopefully members will look at this code
of conduct with uh
intensity and the idea it's a bit
strongly so thank you thank you very
much casakov
i'm not seeing any other hands uh i'm
assuming therefore that we are in
agreement
and in which case then i would like to
move that we will confirm that
resolution
agreed
thank you
right under mate
pay policy revisions and special
severance payments
uh i invite council jefferson
to
thank you um the meeting was held on the
28th of june of the
employment committee and it fell to me
to jared
um
i would refer you to page 36
for the recommendations to council
and would ask that you agree with these
recommendations
hopefully don't worry
thank you i have a proposal can i have a
certainty please
council healing
thank you very much lee
anyone wish to
discuss
this
no
well in that case then our members agree
that this can be
coming off thank you very much
thank you
right
uh item nine
yep we're answer item nine now council
questions
nelly can we just run through those uh
question first question is cancer junior
do you have a supplementary question
yes the supplementary question is that a
number of organizations including swim
england have put forward uh their
concerns about the inflationary
pressures are we taking all that into
your account uh in our medium term
financial strategy for the year ahead
to thank cancer for the questions
thank you question two counselor adam do
you have a supplementary
uh no
thank you
thank you
question three uh councilman
yeah um
thank you very much for
replying can we be kept updated on any
focus
um
sorry
thank you
[Music]
um we shall certainly
um keep the council updated as in more
information
on a final boat i'd just like to say
thank you for keeping hold of all my old
press cuttings i thought my mother was
my biggest fan looks like she's got
competition
thank you
again councilman do you have any
supplemental questions
thank you again and the portfolio holder
can i therefore ask
for for the portfolio order to liaise
with the local government association or
the district council network to raise
this important should be
yes
very succinct thank you
[Applause]
council curtis is not here
question six counselor cleve do you have
a supplementary
thank you very much
right counselor question sorry question
seven seconds
cancer tragedy is not here
moving on from there
[Music]
to council eight council project is not
here
council nine gradually again
[Applause]
council ten council rock do you have a
supplementary question
can i just fall i do apologize cancer i
think we're waving goodbye to our
our guests today bye everybody
[Music]
thanks for
years
coming
bye-bye
[Laughter]
it was lovely to see them and do you
know something they were better behaved
than some of the people i could mention
no no no i'm not saying any names
castle rock uh
no supplementary thank you chairman
thank you
right accounts for all [ __ ]
do you have a supplementary question
and
the currency the money from unit
10
to start off which which is a great
start of this
service
with the extended building work that has
happened in the jurisdiction can i ask
that all the avenues are being explored
to have this vital service open seven
days a week to help the burden on the
warwick a e
what representation will you make on
behalf of the resident of the south
warwick trust
thank you councillor
as you may be aware i'm on the swift
board of governors so it's something
that i raise every single time
um but we're there and there is um
undoubtedly there's a huge huge need
there's also a huge wish that we do open
it
seven days a week but as you're aware
we're still having struggles with um
operating it because of a number of
staff
and that's that's been the problem
throughout but i will keep up the
pressure
on the board as a member
okay council cleve do you have a
supplementary yes
i'll
just say thank you all the customer
service staff
i do know how it works um but just to
follow up according to sbc website
customer
access terminals are currently
not in operation yet they improve access
to eighty percent of the district live
outside of the town
uh and who are also not digitally well
served
due to the current reduced hours and in
view of trying to reduce the reliance on
the car may ask what plans going forward
to reopen the cats
in in the towns of ulster biddeford and
leash it south
studly isil and wellsville to save these
people coming
to stratford thank you
thank you councillor cleveland for
advance warning of the supplementary
um
i know from personal experience that the
customer access terminal in shipston
has been quite tricky to use and i think
other councils might nod their heads
that custom access terminals where they
are
um
my view and i will pursue this uh with
mr patz is that
a we need them to be operating be
perhaps we're all quite conversant with
teams perhaps that might be an easier
way to do it um
added to which uh you will have seen
that we have discussed opening the front
door for long routes which we are going
to do
thank you
council or cop do you have a
supplementary on yours
yes
um
yeah councilwoman thank you very much
for your detailed reply those things in
there i wasn't actually aware of
can i please ask that the wording on
letter on reminders letters regarding
the reason council attacks is looked at
the actual wording of it just to ensure
that no additional stress is being put
on to people who at the moment
are under such undue distress
regarding money matters and make sure
that as a council
though we are still following
legislation we're not inadvertently
adding
to the stress and terror that people are
going through and it is terror because
i've had several phone calls myself
regarding council tax payments from
people who are already struggling
before the next um levy of gas
electricity prices hits
um
can i just ensure that along with
it's not just the wording on the letters
in a daft weight also the envelopes
they're sent out in
people who are struggling already will
see on the envelopes right for district
council
and because they are struggling they
will hide it while them face the issue
can i just suggest that that is
something that is look into
to try to find a way to get people to
see there is help available
without causing him to want to hide
things away in jaws and trying to ignore
it
is that possible to happen
care about the yeah and i'm
fairly happy with the language we use
here in comparison to some organizations
you're all probably familiar with
the arrears letters that are churned out
by orbit which drive me absolutely
ballistic
so
i'm i am really really conscious of the
wording because like you a lot of people
come to me and they are terrified
and they are terrified by what to some
of us would seem quite small sums of
money so i'm
totally with you on that i'm looking at
mr platts he's sitting at the back and
wondering whether we change the
envelopes
or what we say on the outside i imagine
it needs a strap for district council i
think if it's franked
but maybe we could turn it into
something i don't know if it turns into
something else but again i'm aware that
people do put things away in drawers
although at some point
i guess they are going to have to come
out of the doors and the more we can
encourage people
not to hide
their bills um or their arrears the
better because there is help available
for
people from so many of us
i'm sorry hold on a second no i haven't
called you to i'm sorry counselor
we haven't asked you to speak this is
nothing not to do with you
so
sorry thank you okay
yes i i haven't had a nod yet but maybe
we could get different evidence
thank you
right that
concludes the
questions
um item 10 is questions to the leader
just to remind everyone two questions
maximum 30 minutes total time and you
get three minutes
castle junior first uh now that we have
the chancellor is a local mp what
representations has the leader been able
to make about the financial crisis
facing so many of our residents this
coming winter
but you know councillor junior the
honest answer is nobody's become
chancellor
uh only recently
i have made none but rest assured i'll
be raising the issue with him in the
near future
and the
is that your okay
[Music]
across the press and just about
everywhere although on social media
where you're out and about and
everywhere else
do you agree with me leader that we as
councils have responsibility as well on
this so we just mentioned about council
in fact i know in the past couple years
i've certainly dealt with various issues
where people have ended up with bailiffs
turning up and certainly i'd like to
contact miss but each time this district
council has been superb in helping these
people out to compensate the officers
there on that part
but as councils as well we can also
apply a bit of common sense to help
these people sometimes sitting down
talking through and we can sometimes see
difficulties
that they don't necessarily see and we
can sometimes find if help advice they
don't possibly know about
do you think as a district council we
should be making arrests as where as
possible
really matter at this point don't be
afraid to approach us and we'll always
sit listen and find help
yeah yeah
thank you counselor
very thoughtful
i think we
will do what we can
i think what everyone has to accept is
that this cost of living crisis is
serious
it's big
we are looking at probably uh when the
energy price cap is raised in i think
it's september
that's going to be in the order of 3 300
a year
there's not really going to be much
escape from that given gas prices are
world prices not set by the uk
uh it looks as though food prices are
going to continue to escalate
so we will do what we can but the scale
of this
is huge
and i have to say i think it will be
unrealistic
for anyone
to pretend
that the vast majority of people
are actually going to be poorer next
year than they are this year
so i'm sorry that's about as optimistic
as i can get council of rummage
yeah just um i've had several residents
approached me um since the eye laws new
bylaws have been updated
um at the on the wreck on the recreation
ground
and there seems to be some confusion
amongst residents that um
uh
about no cycling on the recreation
ground
and um obviously there's the children's
sort of cycle area that's recently been
built
are they supposed to walk their bikes
there or can they cycle there
to legitimate concern and it doesn't
have
thank you council authority i have to
say that's the kind of detailed question
i will need to ask the relevant people
and get back to you all
casserole as a result of increasing
awareness of the advanced bin collection
event
i and colleagues have had feedback
presidents anticipating difficulties
with blackboard human waste
i'm sorry to be indelicate but if he's
likely to become an urgent excuse for
some
either result of medical circumstances
such as especially in consciousness
so
or for families with nappy disposal
issues
would he ask the portfolio holder to see
what might be done to allay very
considerable concerns
that have been expressed to me about
this
would he also ensure that the contact
center is better briefed to handle
enquiries would he agree with those that
with these distressing health concerns
that they need to be thought about so we
minimize any negative effects
thank you
thank you council rock and can i thank
you for advanced notice of this question
uh i understand you've already been
talking to the portfolio holder i've had
a brief conversation with the portfolio
holder there are some considerable
complexities hidden in this question
we will study it very carefully and we
will take whatever action is appropriate
and get back to you but once again can i
just say thank you for letting us have
sight of this it enables us to tackle it
swiftly and comprehensively
thank you casper
does the leader agree that the current
paralysis of the art of government while
the conservative leadership context is
underway is detrimental
to the progress of policies bills white
papers
important and much needed for our
district area
[Music]
at the end of the day
i think
that the leadership contest has come
about as a result
of
conservatives
frankly losing confidence in the present
prime minister
i think it is absolutely essential we
have a prime minister that everyone can
have confidence in and if that takes
an election campaign to deliver that
i think in the medium to long term that
is hugely advantageous
thank you council field
thanking you for
your comments on elms but following the
lga conference you reported that climate
change
appears to be dropping down the list of
urgent matters
can you update the council as to your
thoughts on the subject bearing in mind
the green issues in the district
thank you councillor fielding
i think the reality is the main topic of
conversation
uh at the lga conference
uh was much more orientated towards the
cost of living crisis than it was to
climate change
i think it is
going to be an interesting challenge as
how one actually manages uh both the
major short-term issues with the
long-term issues
climate change is not going to go away
absolutely true
and in fact in many senses the
what is happening with energy supply and
energy prices
is not going to make it easier to reduce
carbon emissions
i think we will have to deal with issues
as and when they arise but climate
change is definitely not going to go
away but at the moment
most people's focus seems to be on the
cost of living crisis
thank you cancer walcott
thank you
chair
leader i'm sure you'll agree with me
that
this is something that comes up
frequently probably from me
um
regarding caseload that
for all cancers that comes from one
particular housing association
this hasn't changed in the three years
that i've been talking about it in this
chamber
it hasn't got any better i am still
contacted
on a daily basis
from residents who are struggling to
have their housing association follow up
on repairs
follow up on
issues with anti-social behavior
leader would you agree to me
agree with me that
as our council as a whole we need to
find a way to communicate better
with housing associations whose
consistent
lack of care to their residents is
actually causing additional case work
for the councillors
thank you council rollcock
i have to say you are not alone in
getting comments about
a well-known local housing association
uh
i am not sure communication
is actually the root cause of the
problem
uh i know
we take up issues with that well-known
local housing association
very frequently and very often
and it's not only taken up by offices
it's taken up by councillors
uh
we will look again at the issue but as i
say i really do not think communication
is the root cause of the problem
thank you council promise your second
question
last week but we formerly called off the
merger i suggested that we continued as
our group that we had done
stratford's side
who'd been on that joint steering route
that we looked at
continuing look how we could drive this
council forward and reform it
and obviously you were very overloaded
questions at the time i know i didn't
get an answer off that
i think even now we are talking about
cost of living crisis costs for the
council going up and if i'm very honest
i don't think we're going to get much on
central government that so i think as a
council we need to start thinking about
how we could potentially reform
ourselves how we could increase revenue
how we could save revenue
many different issues and i know we
could sit here as a whole big group as a
council and debate this and we'll
probably go around in circles and be
coming back in years time two years time
five years time and so on but i do think
it's probably the time now where we
seriously start looking at what we do
keep a group together based on what
we've been doing over the past year so
we look how we can drive this council
forward so i have to reform it and
probably turn around be briefly honest
we might have to make some very
difficult decisions to put proposals to
put on the table
and we might have some very easy ones
who knows that but i think we now if we
get in here quickly
i think we give ourselves a head start
and i think
that will then help us going forward
because like i said i think combination
across the living and stroke inflation
essential government issues and that
we could find ourselves in difficulty a
few years down the line if we don't
start exploring options early enough but
i think it does have to be across all
the various parts
here independence
get a true idea of what everyone's
actual thoughts are
thank you chancellor bromage for uh
another excellent suggestion
i would agree with you wholeheartedly
that i do not think we will get a
terribly generous settlement for two
years uh
this autumn stroke winter
and it usually arrives fairly late which
makes planning rather difficult
uh i think
picking up and following from
my colleague councillor harvey's
response to one of the counselling
questions
um there is no doubt about it this
medium financial plan we are doing the
end of this year will be challenging
uh just to give you one of the figures
we've already talked about
that if
the settlement pay settlement comes in
three percent above what we budgeted for
we budgeted for three percent
over five years that will actually cost
the council nearly two million
that is a lot of money
we will have to think long and hard
about what we can do and what we can't
do
and i take on board your suggestion
and we will have to think very hard
about what we put together in september
to actually look at the future
and
help shape the decisions but
i would leave nobody in any doubt
i think the next medium-term financial
plan
will be challenging
council curry
thank you chairman
uh leader for the benefit of those
members of the public watching
the media and those lib dem
councillors in attendance
could you possibly explain
that the merger has not
cost
taxpayers 350 000
as extensively
featured and distributed
in the current lib then election
material thank you leader
thank you councillor paris
um
stratford and worried between them spent
three hundred and twenty thousand
on
[Music]
merger related issues
offsetting those worn off savings of
about a hundred and fifty thousand
from having a single
management team during the process
uh in addition to the one-off savings
recurring savings of
572
000 have been delivered from initiatives
such as
the new waste stroke recycling contract
and legal services shared services
uh there may well be other savings
coming from
the process of developing a joint south
warwickshire local plan
by my calculations
that means the
net cost
from the three hundred and twenty
thousand less than hundred and fifty
thousand
was a hundred and seventy thousand
two hundred and seventy one thousand
over the medium term financial plan
period
five years
is one million three hundred and fifty
five thousand
approximately
if you take away the hundred and seventy
thousand net cost
the next savings over the medium term
financial planning period
are 1 million 185
000 pounds
i think it would be fair to say as well
that because we actually did the waste
contract jointly it was a much bigger
contract
and we got more interest than we would
have done had we tried to do it
separately
uh
we have benefited from all the work that
went in to the merger even though the
merger is now off
thank you councillor parry for the
question thank you
how's the project
thank you chair
uh leader uh following the failure of
the merger between stratford and warwick
um
and then following this accusations of
stratfor district council
lacking ambition as opposed to uh
warwick district council is this now an
opportunity for stratfor district
council start building its own housing
demonstrating it still has an ambitious
agenda
the one ambition we certainly don't have
counsellor fighter is to borrow 400
million i want to be absolutely clear on
that
we do keep looking at the opportunities
to actually
build our own houses
it's not straightforward i think we've
looked at it now twice
uh while i've been a counselor
and the difficulty is
the economics don't seem to work out
given the skill at which you've got to
do it and the amount of money we'd have
to do it borrow to do it properly
it's not something we dismiss
but we will do a very thorough
analysis before we actually progress
and i think that is one of the things
we do do very thorough analysis and
consideration anything we do
that's why
we don't rush out and borrow money on
spec
thank you council cleave
um
just had an email i met with ben hambry
works at pieces just had
email from him about parking officer
fisherman's car park i appreciate most
of that is highways but they were they
were issues again with the parking
because the fisherman's car park was
full
and they were talking about looking at
stakeholders as people who were
responsible for the areas around it um
if there's anything we can do
to help with it uh to help with
traffic calming or parking calming if
that's something um so the land opposite
although we can't do anything to do with
the pot stopping and parking there
they're looking for support to stop
people parking in the first place is
there anything that we can do as a
district council to stop them parking on
the verge
um
maybe putting planters anything along
those i appreciate i think that falls in
your ward anyway
so is there something we can do as a
district council to stop parking
thank you
i'm very tempted to say councillor
claimed that we could extend fisherman's
car back
i'm not sure that will go down well
uh
it's something we will look at because
if people are parking on the verge
increasing obstruction
in reality to policing issue but
nevertheless
i mean i know it was a serious issue
last year and it was looked at
and the police were putting cones down
to help prevent it so something will
take up again
thank you i have no more questions oh
counselor junior okay you're um
councillor mills your second question
uh would the uh leader agree that shared
services are common between councils and
could have been achieved irrespective of
anybody
shared services are indeed beneficial
between councils
uh the reality actually is
in sharing services you need both sides
to really play ball
one cannot actually assume that that
will always happen
and i think that is one of the issues
where it sounds really good in theory
but the practice may well be very
different
thanks sherman um leader can i ask you
we'll keep you away
from the district
apart from the heat
uh i think we've already touched on it
uh
from many of the questions today
um
one of the real underlying issues with
the uk
is and i would say this wouldn't i
our economic performance is abysmal
[Applause]
since 2007 it has been
disastrous
our gdp growth is hopeless
our productivity growth is pathetic
and this is the reason why
many people are struggling
real incomes have been constrained
massively
it's
not good news
and
over the weekend
purely out of interest
i looked at
gdp per head for the uk
technically in terms of purchasing power
parities but we won't go there
and
we rank 28th
28th
we are slipping down the table quite
rapidly if we continue the way we are
we will slip down the table even more
rapidly
at the minute
investment is low
the balance of payments is wreckage
interest rates are probably too low and
need to go up we have some real issues
and in all honesty my view is quite
simple keep on with this economic
performance
we will not be able to fund the public
sector we've got
let alone the one that we think we need
the economic performance of the uk
is the main challenge
facing the next government
thank you final question i think cancer
put together
so that's the leader
think that the art brexit negotiated by
the government is affecting the economic
performance of the uk and of our area as
well
sorry comes from pedro could you repeat
the first part of the question does the
leader
believe
that the hard brexit negotiated by the
government is affecting the economic
performance the abysmal economic
performance of the uk
and of area in particular
however one looks at it
we have faced
three major economic crises in a very
short space of time we had the financial
crisis in 2007-8
which dumped a significant blow to the
economy
in particular delta major blow to
financial services which was one of our
most competitive
and
most tax-paying industries
we then had
covered
which dealt another major blow to the
economy one for which we have not
recovered at all
and finally we've got the current war in
ukraine
with the impact on
food prices and energy prices
we've also had
what i think is
a major hit from brexit
i don't have any doubts about it when i
listen to what employers are saying
and the feedback i actually get when i
listen to the west midlands uh
economic interest group
there is no doubt about it most
employers and most businesses have been
slow to adapt
to the changes
uh particularly on exports to europe
i think when you put all those four
together
it really has delivered a hammer blow to
the uk economy
there is though only so much government
could do and one of the things i don't
think has helped
is
i think there has been an attitude
that business doesn't matter
it does
because the reality actually is it's
business that generates the economic
growth generates the tax revenue
and one of the things i do think needs
to happen with the new government is put
much greater emphasis
on ensuring businesses can grow
thank you that's questions
completed thank you very much
um item 11 is for information only it's
the notice of motion plant life been
referred to cavendish on the 7th of
march and the deferred pending report
from officers
moving on to item 12 motions of notice
the first
is the freedom of information requests
and this is being proposed by council
junit
and do you have a secondary
council verdigella thank you very much
indeed
um
once proposed and second did this will
now be referred to the cabinet for
consideration without debate
okay
right thank you the next item then
is playing committee substitutes
uh the motion is uh proposed by council
rock and seconded by councillor fetty
geller
castle rock do you want to
comment
uh
thank you chairman um
and this is a
just a procedural matter i
i believe
and i believe it is non-contentious
because i've had a series of uh
conversations uh conservative leadership
um um
i suggest i don't dwell too long in it
because i'm hoping it's going to be
fairly
non-controversial um
it's to do with basically managing
absences
it seems to be uniquely that we we don't
uh have a proper mexican to do without
having to come about i don't know it's a
result of possibly going from two
committees to one but um perhaps it
would be better to reserve my right to
speak afterwards i see the leader
indicating he wishes to speak and uh
we'll come back to i'll come back to
that thank you council what happens now
thank you council classic jefferson
uh
more than happy to accept
uh this notice of motion about planning
committee substitutes council rock
are there any other speakers on this
if not
oh we all agree
yeah great thank you very much
right
and that brings us to
iphone 13 urgent business none to date
um please note the next meeting is on
the 17th of october so you got a nice
break
refreshed
all happy and coming back for the next
meeting i'll see you then thank you very
much goodbye